this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody because you're
damn right they do
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you thing that you me
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh I bear that you decide
without it
hey yeah let's record a podcast Shawn if
you're ready to record if you could just
give me some sort of signal let me know
that you're ready I suppose that will
work well hello everybody welcome to the
middlemost podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is Joshua fields Milburn's and I
am Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist and we are live today in
Minneapolis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
usually we take your phone calls and
answer them but you're right here right
now why not why not just talk it out
with us so we got a microphone up here
and we'll start with a handful of people
and we have a special guest to death
he's one of my favorite online writers
although he is not online right now he
is non-line as the term I believe he
coined for this and have any of you seen
the documentary we did we put out last
year nice he was actually the last we
kept trying to get him in there and he
kept saying no we just got twisting his
arm enough and we we came out here the
day after Christmas and interviewed him
and it was a very last interview we did
in fact his interview wasn't even in the
film festival version of the film and we
finally were able to pin him down and
once you get him talking he might not
stop so we put seatbelts on all of your
seats and we'll all just be mongering on
for the next five or six hours I believe
but it's one of my favorite online
writers he's an all-around outstanding
human being he's the author of a book
called in and he is currently offline
right now or it's actually different
from offline he is non-line right now
we're going to talk about that he's
going to be here helping us answer your
questions ladies and gentlemen please
welcome a local hometown boy here we
have Patrick roan
[Applause]
[Music]
so everyone who's listening we're always
hugging I think they know well Patrick
welcome oh you got you got to flip it up
there there we go all right so we have a
microphone up here someone has to this
is like the Minnesota knife thing it's
going to be three hours before we before
we get a thank you for breaking this you
I'll tell you you might want to ask us
questions in line the hug line but we
really don't have time for that now is
the time to ask your questions so yes we
have to the event we venture we do a hug
line we take pictures and all that fun
stuff and I'd love to answer 500
people's questions tonight in line but
we won't be able to do that so what time
for our hugs and all that other fun
stuff afterward but now is the time for
the question so if you got them bring
them on up how do you just give us your
name where you're from and whatever your
question is hi I'm a Murray and I'm from
Fargo North Dakota of course yeah oh
thanks I love Fargo
so my question kind of in all of your
travels and perhaps in talking with
Colin Ryder even with the refugee family
work with
is there something extra nefarious about
America's particular brand of
consumerism that makes minimalism and
intentional ISM something we should
strive for so well let's talk about this
I think it's there is a some minimalism
is obviously not a new idea right but so
you can go back as far as any major
world religion you can go back to the
Stoics you can go back to the row and
and you have these similar ideas of
intentional intentional living or simple
living I think what's different now is
we have a new problem and it's called
consumerism and especially
post-industrial revolution but
especially post-world War two we've gone
from this culture of fulfilling needs to
creating false false needs this desire
for things that we think we need even
though we may or may not and
becoming harder to sort of decocked and
and decide what's which of those needs
are actual needs and which of those are
imaginary needs and so I think the new
problem today is we have more access to
stuff than ever and access is a great
thing but it's becoming very difficult
for us to to discern whether or not
those things add value to our lives
because advertisers and demographers do
a damn good job of selling us asking us
to to work jobs that we hate to buy [ __ ]
we don't want to impress people we don't
like and and and so in the Western world
do do we have the luxuries of access yes
absolutely in fact I hope that we move
more to a culture of access and we're
seeing more and more and more of that
with the online world thankfully no
longer do I need to own 2,000 DVDs right
you turn on Netflix and you have
functionally unlimited access to movies
and so I think that that's one thing or
whether it's music I don't have to own
CDs it's right there on my phone now so
that type of access is good but then
we're also faced with the paradox of
choice
I feel like great good but now you can
own it all instantly but now you can own
it all instantly and that's a problem
too
yeah I agree with the paradox of choice
Lange and it's something I faced one of
these I don't I don't do streaming music
services for that very reason because as
I get that I'm like all I I don't know
what a random play you know
I like it all you know seriously is like
just yeah I like all music so it's easy
for me to just not paying attention to
it and play the stuff that I haven't
that I like I mean the problem with
having access to all the world's stuff
is you have access to all the worlds
stuff and and how do you you know how do
you dig through that how do you discern
yeah I would argue that that's you know
just another flip side of the problem it
may not be taking up space in your home
but it's taking up space in your mind
that constantly being bombarded with
choice the other beauty about
simplifying and is actually having less
choice so that you can free your mind up
to make other more important choices
think about other more important things
or think about nothing at all which is
also important for your mind to do can
you talk a little bit about maybe the
the choice of because you made a choice
to limit your choices really I guess at
least in a roundabout way
yeah well within a very in a very
intentional way and so you have publish
online for a long time whether it's 20
years there you go and so since there
has been an online I've been publishing
online and so whether that is to Twitter
or to your own personal blog which is
logged at Patrick roam net for those of
you keeping score here and who want to
read some grace up there's it's still
out there it's just not being updated
currently that is correct so what what
what spurred that choice well a large
number of things like I said I've been
publishing online for as long as there
has been an online to BBS is back in the
day I'm old so you know I the kids don't
know about the BBS but I was all about
the BBS back in the day down lowing up
with you know on the modem is great and
I judge to to these various online
things and get feedback from other
people who are dialing into the BBS and
forming this nice little community and
that was great but even before that
before self-publishing become a fun
you know even as a kid I was typing
things up on my grandmother's IBM
Selectric - she was a university
professor just over literally half mile
away at in the African American Studies
department at the University of
Minnesota for 30 years but I would type
on her typewriter and write up these
little books of poetry or little short
stories and whatnot and then I would
copy him on the copy machine that she
had in her office and then I would fold
those up and sell them to friends and
family so I've been publishing for a
very long time but you know the there
was a time when that was like I was
writing with the thought that it was
just going to be me and people that
wanted to humor me reading it and and I
didn't have the immediacy of publishing
to to a website where I knew pretty much
as soon as I published it you know
hundreds of people within the first hour
would be reading it thousands perhaps
within the day and who knows how many
after that and that was great and this
exciting and but it also I think changed
my writing I wasn't taking any time to
to Park it for a while to go back and
reread it say oh maybe I could say more
about this or maybe I could change that
or maybe I could you know like I used to
what I like the delayed gratification
say yeah exactly
you know and so I thought hmm I wonder
what that would be like now I wonder
what it would be like if I didn't have
that outlet if that wasn't a choice like
it didn't used to be a choice I wonder
how my writing would change especially
as there more than a few book projects
I've kind of made various and roads on
and other things I wanted to try to see
I just really wanted to see what would
be different if I didn't have that
choice and could go back to the old days
and maybe type things up on the
typewriter and copy them out of machine
and so - family and friends
so your person as you're approaching
three months on on this we couldn't
figure out a good name for experiments
probably not the right word yeah my
partner Rebecca does something called a
reset and this maybe this almost feels
like maybe it is a bit of a reset for
you yeah yeah I I definitely am
resetting and going back to a previous
time and trying to see how that makes
any sort of difference or change in my
writing especially now that I'm older
I'm a much hopefully better writer
mature more mature writer and then my
hope is that it will improve things I
don't know
remains to be seen I have no time limit
on this do you have any initial
observations some initial lessons that
you've learned yeah so initial lesson
number one is yes I I now take the time
to you know I have this stuff that I've
been building up and I've been going
back and kind of rereading it and
working on it and I have various things
that are kind of in just this process of
you know finished but not finished right
finished but open to the potential for
becoming better changing what-have-you
so that's one thing and also just you
know I thought I would miss Twitter a
lot so I was a pretty active Twitter
reader and Twitter user more so than
most of the other social networks but I
found surprisingly enough that it wasn't
Twitter that I missed the most and has
been the hardest to not have that
instinctive reaction to post to its
Instagram of all things which surprised
me because I'm not a photographer at all
but I don't know there's a much more
intimate experience with there
especially because it was mostly like
photos of my daughter who's you know
well extremely photogenic and and you
know who I just love to death and so
yeah that's that's been the hardest part
is the one thing I've actually had to
recreate for myself as it were so I use
a journaling app on the iPhone
on the Mac and such two is called day
one but what's nice about is that you
know allows you to put a picture in
their little journal entry and so I've
essentially been using that like
Instagram hi basically using it as an
Instagram replacement it's just an
Instagram where I'm the only one who
ever sees the photos and there's no
liking and commenting and oh my gosh
she's so cute there's none of that no
you can leave commented on your on
yourself oh yeah I could I could I
haven't really scratched that it yet but
yes okay you know it's when he brought
the refugees when when they first
arrived in Missoula Montana it was just
after Thanksgiving so it was like really
really cold so like huge huge shock to
him and you know as a minimalist I was
wondering I'm like like I first of all I
would never tell anyone what they should
or shouldn't have but I was wondering
like what how many things are they going
to take because there's this wonderful
organization that are called soft
landing and they curate a bunch of
donations kitchenware you know bathroom
products diapers I mean like you name it
they have the essentials so I take them
to soft-landing just like a day or two
after they arrived in Missoula Montana
and of course like we've got boxes and
boxes and boxes of stuff that we're
bringing to their new apartment because
it's an empty apartment they came to
Missoula with you know three three bags
with some clothes in it and of course
they needed some kitchenware they needed
some silverware they needed you know a
few things so Christmas was coming up
and I am part of an amazing volunteer
team who just everyone on that team just
like pours her heart out into this and
they all I mean I didn't I did not get
them any I take that back I did get them
a Christmas gift
um they kept asking for Tess which is
what you make engira out of which is
like they were from Eritrea but Eritrea
used to be Ethiopia and essentially it's
kind of the same food they both use
this and jeera and tes is what they used
to make it and they're like you know we
went to the store and we got some tests
but it's not any good
like we need any better tests so I like
went around all the stores and could not
find it was all the same brand I'm not
going to mention the brand's I don't
like you know fashioning any brand of
tests but I'm sure other people use it
that's great
they just weren't happy with it so I
went online and like ordered them some
test flour and like that's what I gave
them for Christmas and I guess it was
kind of like a Christmas gift for myself
because they made some amazing interior
and Eritrean food that was just awesome
um but after Christmas like they I mean
whatever they had in their house was
like doubled because of the the
wonderful team that I'm part of who is
just again just pours our heart out into
this and there was a certain point where
the family you would ask them do you
need anything and they're like no we do
not need anything else maybe some more
tests like I mean those things that they
like things that they actually needed
and wanted but I was just really
surprised because I thought like coming
because they it's not like they left
their country and then came right to the
States I mean it was like a five year
process of them going through getting
vetted they were in refugee camps a
really just amazing story but they never
had a lot and I was very interested to
see like how they would react being over
here in the States and it didn't take
long for them to realize like oh wow if
we keep asking like we're going to keep
getting stuff and then we're going to
have to like make room for the stuff and
we don't have any room for this stuff
but people coming from a place where
they had nothing yeah they certainly
took like as much as they could that
what they needed and maybe they had you
know two spatulas and said in one
spatula I mean maybe they had a little
bit more than what they needed but it
didn't take long before they started
saying no can you american-style storing
your [ __ ] at my hair right
that's your question thank you very much
howdy hi my name is Laura
I'm from Chaska and I just want to hear
your thoughts like during my minimizing
process I've come to realize that I kind
of collect things like soap and candles
and like I'm a knitter so I collect yarn
as well and now I'm being more
deliberate with what I'm buying but I
still have a lot of stuff to get through
and so I'm curious to hear your thoughts
about kind of using up rather than like
donating or throwing away or you know
just getting rid of and like making
trying to use your stuff up
intentionally you probably have more
than one roll of toilet paper too don't
you we do ryan rations out the squares
with Mariah which she's got more
bathrooms than humans so she needs that
grey that make sense right so so what
kind of supply are we talking about our
Costco level supplies are we just
talking about my boyfriend may say yes
uh-huh you know what kind of stuff
specifically mostly soap and candles and
yarn those are the big ones okay so I
like to delineate between just-in-case
items remember just in case the three
most dangerous words in the English
language and just for win items now
there are some things like toilet paper
is the prime example I know I'm going to
use toilet paper I hope that I'm going
to use tape we hope you're going to use
toilet paper - okay and so if I'm
certain I'm going to use it then it's a
just for win item now I have to be
honest with myself because then we can
start justifying a lot of stuff like
yeah well you know I've got 30 coffee
mugs and you know that's for when those
other 28 get dirty right
and and the truth is no I know that I'm
never going to use more than a couple
coffee mugs or whatever and so I'm just
honest with myself about that but that's
not always easy and so once I've parcel
and said okay this is just the case item
this is just for win item then I look at
it just for one night and say do I have
enough space to store these things so
that they're not taking up too much
space and on the open they're not
cluttered they're not your aesthetically
unpleasing and and it's so that I'm
totally fine with it I mean I I buy bulk
toilet paper sometimes and it's okay and
and I know like something for a week
you're just but do you buy one roll at a
time I couldn't tell how many people
like tweet me and ask me do you buy one
roll so you should be like no I buy a
one square at a time I decided to
replace respond with toilet paper but I
do have to talk back side of getting the
one ply though she's very frugal so yeah
I guess my point is is like you have to
ask yourself some questions do I have do
I have adequate space for this and right
now it sounds like the sometimes puzzle
is a little tension in the household
okay yeah yeah you probably on this page
for thin and and here's what to say
because I can tell that you're willing
to let go you're asking these questions
someone else will be able to use it and
you will be able to reacquire it here's
the cool thing though you'll find out a
lot of stuff you won't ever actually
reacquire anyway because it's not toilet
paper it's some stuff you probably
aren't going to use or someone else can
use it before you do when was the last
time you lit candles or how often do you
light candles I'm trying to use some of
them up before we move so I had already
going earlier today she later you got a
blue bow lower your left right
am i just picturing like scented candles
and you got like vanilla and cinnamon
and apple pie all going on a like one
time animal smell amazing they're so so
you're about to move is that the deal
yeah yep end of June were must see your
Realtors going to love you because
they're going to save a crap-ton on
chocolate chip cookies and lemon because
they're not have to do any of those
tricks because you can have those
candles going the house to sell
fantastic yeah I think you know for me
for stuff like that like like we have
some candles we don't light them all the
time but like Mariah and I we will have
candles for I would have no candle
candles and fills up to me but Mariah
likes having some candles and I'm like
okay like I love her I appreciate her I
accept her so you know that is not a
hard compromise for me to be like all
right let's get some candles let's not
fill our closets with candles but yeah
let's let's have some candles for some
you know times here and there and
definitely for some emergencies and what
we do is just put like just a limit on
what we can have and it looks like
really simple advice but hey that's what
we do we get simple advice um but no I
mean at the end of the day I would just
you know ask myself like okay when's the
last time I used these candles not
forcefully because I was moving but
when's the last time I like really
wanted to light a candle and if the
answer was oh you know was it was three
months ago then I would plan and there's
you know three months increments I guess
but you know the beautiful thing about
the just-in-case rule is it really does
hold true like you can get any
especially in a city of access like this
you can get anything you absolutely need
in less than 20 minutes for less than
$20 and that might sound like like
someone out there might be thinking like
why would I do why would I go and spend
twenty dollars every single day on that
just in case item and spend that time
that's a lot of money over you know
however many years the trick is though
we don't use it that often like Josh and
I we live in the middle of nowhere
Montana and we made like between the
both of us we may have had to abused it
like once or twice through the six years
that we've had this website I can count
of one hand combined how many times Josh
and I have had to use that at the end of
the day you could hold on to every
everything in your home that you have
right now anyone out there who has a
hoard of just incase items there are a
million a billion other just in case
items you don't have you'll never have
everything just in case so getting over
that syndrome is probably the biggest
piece of advice I would I would
recommend now let's list as your guy I
think this is an interesting question
for you because there's a there's a
surface question here what are we
talking about earlier today a coffee
every story is two stories yes what the
story's about is every every story is
two things what the story is about and
what the story is really about yeah so
what the story is about here is just the
case I know that's a surface level thing
that is veneer and then the second thing
is the household tension right and and
because that's going to happen in any
household and so thankfully if you're a
minimalist you have to live with someone
who is equally as minimalist right
definitely unfortunately I don't hire
facts I live with two people who are
definitely not minimalist my wife and my
daughter in fact they're maximalists the
maximalist calm I believe is going to be
their website by the way don't be here
next week yep look for the documentary
on Netflix so no seriously uh yeah I
don't live with minimus at all and I
live in a very large home which is
actually one of the three homes we own
why am I here who are you you FRA I am a
complete fraud yes it is true and and
yeah it's it's one of those things that
that's been a working process for us I
certainly came into the relationship
with myself being in a completely
different place as far as my my box
about this my thoughts about simplicity
and having less and that sort of thing
and that actually came out of out of
poverty um you know this is where I get
to check my privilege at the door and
and she she never had that um and she
comes from a much different place and
has a much different kind of philosophy
and what and it still works and it works
because because I what was the acronym
the term the the series you came up for
it which i think is fantastic it was
like three years ago Patrick and we had
a conversation but with Patrick about
understanding other people because if
this comes up all the time it's it's
easier for me to be a minimalist even
even with a family because my partner is
a minimalist and while Ryan's partner
Mariah she doesn't identify as a
minimalist she's farther on that side of
the spectrum for sure and but we also
love each other and so finding that love
has to do with understanding the other
person so the acronym was was Tara t-ara
and sort of working through the steps so
first is with the T is already a hallow
rating it right you know at first you're
going to tolerate this other person this
other person's habit she she has
tolerated me equally my desire to like
take all this stuff that she's
collecting and throw it out the window
as soon as it comes to the house right
it's so easy to get rid of other
people's stuff it really is fantastic
and the view from the high horse is
great let me tell you see a long way
but but yeah so you go through this
tolerance kind of phase where users kind
of like grouchy more crap but then
there's the acceptance yes that's a
second letter so tolerance is kind of
like the weak virtue right it's not
going to last very long enough you're
just constantly tolerating each other
and your neighbors and your stuff pretty
soon there's going to be a fight yeah um
but then you can have to accept okay on
here's the thing you're not going to
change somebody else you are never ever
going to change somebody else you cannot
change other people you can change
yourself maybe maybe but you can't
change other people for sure um and so
therefore you have to accept them or not
um but if not well guess what I could
see another marriage but assuming that's
not what you want um do you you you have
to find a way to kind of accept that
looks like okay I'm not going to change
this person this is just something we're
going to have to work through and that's
where you get past that tolerance phase
and you accept and the moments you
accept you've you've then committed to
finding a solution and that solution is
going to first come with the our respect
right you're going to have to respect
the the wants needs desires wishes of
that other person you're going to have
to find a way to do it it may not align
with your own but you're going to have
to find a way to say you know what I
respect their their their position on
this matter of their choice on this
matter it's got to be a two-way street
yes
yeah keep in mind everything I'm saying
also comes from she has to put up with
yo mister you know let's throw it all
out you know and and there's not a lot
of my stuff to throw out so let's start
with yours
you know or or even worse you know look
at all this stuff I threw away your turn
that never works i'ma find ya and so and
so that's where you get hafta once you
respect where it's coming from then you
have to actually find a way to
appreciate that as crazy as that sounds
the fact is is that my wife is very
she's frugal Ashley you know she likes
finding things for either cheap or free
and that's also her crutch right you
know the fact is you know it can easily
become an excuse it's tapered it was
free within our curve I couldn't not
take it right and that's you know that's
that kind of slippery slope that comes
in but the desire that's behind it is
she really does think through like oh
this this would make Patrick and my are
Beatrix or our daughter or so happy or
wow this would make things so much
easier if we had this salad spinner you
know and even though I don't cook
whatsoever
gosh Patrick does all the cooking it
would make him happy it would make his
life easier look I got you the salad
spinner I don't necessarily wash the
lettuce just just okay do you ever come
over for dinner
they have the misters in the grocery
store I rely on that watches the country
likes to inoculate his guests when their
favorite dinner okay it's all right no
it's no one has gotten ill for my food
at least that I've known about at least
not in my house
I've never had to carry them out so but
I but I set for it's coming is coming
from a good place is coming from a place
of wanting to be good to do good to make
others happy to make herself happy to
make our lives better to make our lives
easier to to make our lives you know to
replace this rug that that we've had
forever and maybe the cats have peed on
it a couple of times and sure we've been
able to get the same cleaner out but
here I got this new rug so we don't you
know and just stuff like that and so yes
you have to find the find the way to
appreciate it after you respect it and
once you do that and assuming it's going
both ways assuming it's going for you
there's there's love there you you how
can i how can i her desire to make me
happy or to make our daughter happy and
how can she be searched mine desire to
make myself happy or to make our lives a
little bit better and easier with the
minimalism the simplicity that I bring
into it and so yeah we find a way to
love each other's differences that way I
don't know how much that helps you get
rid of yarn I guess I said no thanks to
your question appreciate it thank you
thanks honey hello I'm Elena I'm from
Roseville I'd like to start with a very
short story very short serendipitous
story which is that the documentary hit
Netflix in December right yes I
cancelled Netflix in November yes right
but in April a friend of mine put
Netflix on my playstation without asking
my permission
and so I logged in so I couldn't help
myself and the first thing I watched was
the minimalist documentary
and I covered my TV with a scarf
immediately afterward can't I'm sorry or
you're welcome I don't know thank you I
just started again like yesterday so in
a month and I did everything I could to
do the minimalist lifestyle and I'm on
my way and I'm very excited about where
I am I was actually moving so it's a
really good timing and I kind of did the
packing party mentality but my old
apartment is just full of all the crap I
don't want and I don't know how to get
rid of it
the things that are still racist is the
stuff still there yeah so I have I have
a month of overlap ok cool so that's
actually convenient it's so convenient
like the new landlord was like I got to
fill this place in May and I'm like you
know what it's probably worth it let's
do it the stuff that I'm really stuck on
and the question that I now have is the
stuff that I've accumulated that was
sort of the this is the person I want to
be stuff the stuff that I you know the
books that I thought like the ideal me
would read and the movies that the ideal
me would watch and know about and be
able to talk about and so that stuff is
really hard to get rid of because it
feels like I don't know which part of my
journey that fits into does it fit into
the getting rid of it so I can make a
room for other suffers this the stuff
that I'm making room for and I don't
necessarily know how to differentiate
those things hillarie 23 okay so I'm 35
and I can tell you right now I aspire to
be my 40 year old self that's my ID my
ideal me right and I could tell you that
my 40 year old self books a lot my mine
eleven forty year old life looks very
similar to my 35 year old life but there
will be some shifts some pivots and the
cool thing about pivots is you don't
notice the changed unless you pivot five
or ten degrees in one direction the
small change because sometimes that's
what we we try to do is we say oh my god
I don't like this I'm going to pendulum
is going to swing all the way other way
and that can be helpful sometimes but
but sometimes it may it may be
overwhelming and you swing right back
and so
what this request you have to ask
yourself and maybe answer answer a
little bit right here what what is that
ideal self
well what's idea and you said I see my
ideal self reading these books or or
watching these films or doing these
things what is your ideal self a great
question yeah so so I think the best way
to answer that question is to get really
clear on what your values are a really
really clear and there are four types of
values I won't be there everyone over
the head with them here but because if
we can go into a 20 minute discussion on
values but what I'll tell you is go back
and listen to a we did a values episode
episode 69 at the podcast and I think
there four types of values you have your
foundational values the base that
everything else is built on you have
your core values these are the things
that are really important to you they
shape your beliefs and they often
determine what direction you're going to
go on we have your minor values things
you like and you want and you get value
from but there aren't absolutely
essential and then we have the most
dangerous category the imaginary values
and these are the things we usually
spend our days on scrolling incessantly
through Facebook or or incessantly
checking email 40 50 150 times a day and
you're constantly going through our
smartphones whatever it may be these
things can be valuable it can usually be
minor values but when we take it to an
extreme they start wasting our time and
there are net negative and so it doesn't
get really clear on what our values are
before we're going to determine what
kind of person want to be I bet you once
you figure out what those values are
you'll very quickly be able to say this
thing doesn't serve my values this thing
doesn't this thing doesn't by the way if
you're how long has it been since you've
been out of the apartment you you're not
you haven't been living there all month
ah yes twenty days okay nice and and are
the things over there that you miss
right now a couple like right bathmat
like I'm pretty sure I'm going to die
every time I get out of the show okay
and the garbage can because going to the
kitchen to throw away like my makeup
wipes is getting a little old but
besides that
is I could pretty much get rid of that
stuff now it's just doing it in a
ecologically friendly way
interesting so so here here they here a
couple quick quick tips for you go get
your bath mat in your trash can I'm on
it that that's the first thing right and
everything else is pretty much just the
case item it sounds like maybe one or
two other things but I would identify
those things before you go back there
because you're going to go there and
you're going to identify 413 things at
first glance I need all of those things
and so the the next thing I'm going to
recommend to you is have a yard sale
room and you don't have to actually yard
sale you can invite a bunch of friends
over our friend Colin did that I just
today oh nice some of it hurt so much
and not much went but the few things
that I'm like oh it's a really good
season of Rhoda so here's here's where
you are wrong okay
you you're supposed to the yard sale
room and then send the people in there
and they come out with the things and
they don't show you that they took but
it hurt and so if people leave with the
things that you don't know what they
left with you just start forgetting
about the things that you had in there
remember when Ryan had 80% of the stuff
still in boxes and he couldn't remember
what was most of the boxes because we
work our asses off to buy a bunch of
stuff that isn't doing its job it's not
making us happy and so if you out of
sight out of mind is the old sort of a
Pithom that that is that that's your
best bet and also identify some things
you can sell especially if you have any
debt and figure out if you can sell some
you know set a threshold it could be 20
bucks could be 250 bucks whatever maybe
so you can pay off some debt everything
else let it go
yet the books really stand out to me
it's you said you bought a bunch of
books to read to fit this lifestyle that
you thought you would have one day and
the only thing I could think of is like
if I bought like a garage full of tools
it would not make me a mechanic
and at the end of the day I don't need
all those tools to be mechanic either
however maybe that is a hobby I wanted
to pick up but I certainly wouldn't just
go out and buy a bunch of tools and then
think like well I gotta leave it if I
have the tools that eventually that's
going to force me to go out there and
work on cars um I would say the books
are obviously stressing you out there
are people out there and there are
mechanics out there who would say I do
have a bunch of tools and they add a
bunch of value to my life and I'd say
great but for me they wouldn't same
thing with you for books if I had a
library full of books or just you know
bookshelf of books that didn't read they
wouldn't they would have a bunch of what
Josh said earlier like imaginary value
now if you said to me I've got a library
of books and I love to turn the pages
and I love lending them out to friends
and they come back and we talk about the
books and I love how the books smell and
I spend a lot of time in that room that
I would say keep your books but they're
obviously causing a lot of stress and
letting them go is definitely going to
make you feel better in your situation
um the good news too even with that
amazing season of Rhoda okay you may be
the only season I'm not sure hell yes I
was I can get away with saying this
because I'm I'm turning 50 this year
that you weren't even born when Rory was
it Mary Tyler Moore is still in the
collage with the book the beautiful
damaging like that season of Rhoda and
even the books that you get rid of I
promise you if you get if you want home
and get rid of all that stuff tonight
like you would still have access to
those things yeah I mean libraries do a
great job of well having books but also
David ears also DVDs especially maybe
these a bro-down
yeah but a turn and well you can also
request like if they don't have a
certain season or something like I know
Missoula you can request the season they
will find it yeah they will bring it to
the library in the out put it on their
shelves yep so it's very easy to have
access to that I say their way to rent
DVDs rent DVDs is absolutely free
Kuroda's on rural area
and you could subscribe now for $10 a
month oh I already canceled that but I I
just I want to just say one thing and
that is while you know certainly
thinking about future you is important
and maybe you know kind of what you want
to do where you want to go who you want
to be if you're not if you're not
working on first opening up who you are
open up who you are now yeah because
what you will find is that when you open
up who you are the universe will will
will enter in and allow you to be who
you aspire to be that's beautiful
thank you guys so much thank you thank
you all right well before we move on
here for anyone who's listening to this
at home if you have a comment or tip for
anyone who asks us a question so far
today or anyone who's getting ready that
it's a question as well you can leave a
voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or you can send a
voice memo from your phone over to
podcast at the minimalists com we will
air our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode Ryan you know what time
it is um I think it is hashtag ask the
minimalist lightning around 30 so we're
going to move on to our lightning round
we usually answer questions from Twitter
and Instagram and Facebook were active
and listen on all of those platforms but
since you're here tonight we will answer
your questions now you can answer a
regular question what we usually try to
do is we spend a week crafting a really
short pithy answer it's less than 140
characters that you can share on social
media but since we don't have seven days
in about seven seconds to respond to you
we've turned it into a battle and I
don't think Patrick even knew this we're
roping him into this battle tonight and
so what we'll do is we'll we'll answer
your question was something that we
think is treatable and and we might lose
might like
yeah talk a little bit to get that
tweetable answer but we'll get there
eventually indeed and you get to vote on
who wins so you ought to make noise for
whoever's whoever sounds if someone's
answer is really profound to you then
yeah make some noise for it
let's go man what's your name Shawn
Casper from Hot Springs South Dakota
thanks for coming man thanks are really
hung blacklisted from comments or what's
that really blacklisted from comments oh
no I had a brother okay so I read three
of your books right now I think the the
first one minimalism the second one was
all that remains and the third one's the
essentials and as I was reading that
third book I thought about you Josh when
you had commented and actually tonight
to when you're you shared this story
about your mother and you said you saw
those boxes and there one two three four
and they're taped up and they're they're
really taped up you know they haven't
been open as well you kind of imply you
think to yourself what was she holding
on to right that I'm not in those boxes
the memories are within us and I was
reading that last book essentials and I
kind of came across that and had an
epiphany that maybe the memories weren't
for her right maybe the memories were
for you and then when Niger and yeah I
uh I like Josh this guy's now like you
both but I like your writing style my
boy has better hair that's good I don't
worry I like you right yeah you know
what I'm just going to drop Mike walk
away no but you know what when I was
when I was going through that though
yeah I just I started thinking about
purpose meaning you talked about purpose
meaning earlier and without that those
four boxes so to say we may not be here
tonight right so those four boxes had a
really large impact and not only your
life but in everybody's life that's
hearing tonight sure so I mean I just
think that's incredible and my question
for you all tonight is Viktor Frankl
with man's search for meaning yeah I was
wondering if any of you had the
opportunity to read that book and if so
have you noticed a direct correlation
between Mansoor
remaining and also some of the
fundamentals behind minimalism yes yeah
definitely and I mean I think I think
his story is is inspirational and it's
the epitome of struggle and I mean we
all sort of have inciting incidents
right and and mine was you know the four
boxes and and my mom died and also on
marriage ending and and those two events
happening back to back was sort of like
a collision for me but I certainly
didn't suffer anything like like Victor
Franco was it was bad for me and and so
if there is any any correlation between
them is you is that we all experience
suffering in some way the question then
this isn't my tweetable answer let me
let me try I'm trying to boil it down
here we all we all experience car
crashes in life the question is isn't
about the crash it's about what we do
after the crash was one person
it's funny my mom she did I say had a
shitty childhood like that doesn't even
because I have respect for my mother and
I love her I don't want to go in to all
the like nitty-gritty stuff but multiple
times like she has apologized to me for
the things that I grew up with and I
used to really yearn for that apology
but after kind of starting this whole
journey and having these stories I'm
like mom Mike you know I realized if it
wasn't for all your shitty decisions
like I wouldn't have what happens
perspective long live um you know if I
could go back and change things man I
mean there are certainly some things I
would like to change but you know I can
only accept what has happened and it has
made me the person I am today there's no
doubt about that I guess what my
tweetable answer would be trying to boil
this down for us to make a major change
in our lives sometimes we have to have a
major catastrophic happen but we
shouldn't have to wait for that moment
[Applause]
so Wow okay
I'm sorry I was so exploring the the
Viktor Frankl connection in one of the
things that you know we are reminded of
on a daily basis today is man's capacity
to be inhumane to other men men being
humanity inclusive and so you know I
don't know making making that that leap
seems almost I don't know dismissive um
so I won't write here's what I will say
the past informs us to how we should
move forward in the future but not how
we should be open and living today right
every day is is you know the past has
brought us to this moment right and
everything that's happened in the past
has brought us to this moment
and yet we still in this moment have the
chance to choose another path to choose
it or another direction every single
moment that passes we can make that
choice we can decide okay I'm not happy
or I'm not satisfied or I or I am happy
I am sad I want more of this or I want
less of that every single moment we have
that opportunity to make that choice and
there's no guarantee no guarantee but
we'll get another moment right um and so
as a small be Buddhist I try not to
focus on you know kind of what that
future is nor do I necessarily need to
focus on the past in as much as it in
for
it helps me make that choice on where to
move forward so if I were to boil that
down into a tweet you had like three
awesome lines in there
every moment is a fresh opportunity to
make a new start
yeah yeah thanks your pleasure brother
appreciate it hey thank you all you
inspire me that's why it's out there and
I had time to reflect and I mean really
you had meaning to my life so thank you
thank grateful for the thank you man
it's going good
I'm cleaning them from Fairbanks Alaska
oh did you know you're from freer Bank
I'm from Fairbanks Alaska so I moved to
Duluth Minnesota now swear I'll oh okay
all right I moved there I convinced my
dad after I graduated high school when I
was 18 that I wasn't going to go to
college that I wanted to pursue the
Olympic dream to be a curler Oh dice and
me and Mike one of my friends so I'm
here with tonight I got the email two
weeks ago that we are in the Olympic
Trials in November yeah nice yeah
wait question for you are you going to
curl at the st. Paul club while you're
here well yeah we were down here we had
a practice weekend so I thought OHS can
be nothing like it were you guys also
better so along that whole journey of
the past four years moving years before
that we have went all kinds of amazing
places like Denmark and China and Russia
and Eveleth Minnesota and so along the
way I'm not necessarily one to hop to
the first gift shop and like my teammate
did in Russia buy a t-shirt of Putin
riding a grizzly bears I'd consider
getting like a today later I got to see
that nicer but along the way we have
acquired a decent amount of stuff when
you add each tournament they give you
some memorabilia whether it's your
athlete pass or you know on the
occasional time we do actually when
something you get a medal or some sort
of award or plaque I have someone who
moves around and travels a lot I can't
bring this whole entourage of pins and
pitchers and medals and stuff with me so
my question is drawn the line from you
know the one you know the World
Championship medals all the way down to
just the you know the athlete lanyard
that you got from one of these events
where we're where would you guys
recommend drawing a line in in that well
when you win a gold medal don't throw
that away you can sell that [ __ ] yeah
joshua curlers that make like this off
that i might be able in Subway's okay
it's not real gold oh we got a silver
last year so far we got guys nice so I
mean I can't say what I recommend for
you I could tell you what I would do
personal and what I have done personally
so I had a lot of trophies and I mean
that figuratively
well actually literally to remember we
did bid President's Club so so I in the
corporate world
I managed 150 retail stores which I know
is really ironic with the whole
minimalism thing but I several years I
was like the top performer in the
company and went on to this President's
Club tripping on the trip they give you
this fancy dinner with mediocre food and
and they hand you this large glass
trophy it's like a corporate version of
like a kid's softball trophy or
something and it looks like a weapon and
and like you put it on your mantle or
you put it on above the fireplace and I
had several of them and I guess
theoretically they look nice but they
didn't really and
and I can tell you when I walked away
from that I also walked away from from
those because I realized that the trophy
is here so here's my short answer the
the winner is not determined by the
trophy there we go
[Applause]
souvenirs is what stood out to me like
I've been on some really cool trips over
the last like three years and I will
tell you like the first time I left
North America well when we in 2014 we
were lucky enough to go to like the UK
and Ireland on our tour and stuff and
Australia do you go to the cliffs of
Marwin here and I yes we pray no it's
unbelievable unbelievable unbelievable
it was even like a crappy day and it was
still unbelief but we had blue sky
outside yeah let's go stuff to go back
but yeah I wanted to get like souvenirs
I had that impulse I should say doesn't
really want to but I had that impulse to
like get souvenirs like the first city
we did was London and I'm like oh man I
got to get like some little British flag
type souvenir or something and I was
quickly able to like talk myself out of
it because at the end of the day it was
documented plenty between Facebook and
Instagram so like I and Plus you know
taking pictures on my phone I put those
into my computer they go up into the
cloud so like I had plenty of things
that could trigger the memories when I
was there in the UK um and I just
quickly talked myself out of souvenirs
because if I bought a bunch of souvenirs
I'm proud of home they would they would
just sit there and you know what if I
had maybe one souvenir someone might say
oh where did that cool thing come from
but when you have a house full of
souvenirs people don't ask you about
that like sit here and tell me about the
30 souvenirs that you have tell me each
story about that um so I mean to me it
wasn't it was very easy for me to
kind of put aside that feeling the
trophies um the gold medals like the
things that your your I'm sure going to
win as the years go on I guess I would
say this is kind of in the same vein
what you were saying my short answer
would be even if you want a gold medal
it doesn't matter how many you hold on
to you're going to work your ass off to
get another one next year I like that so
I'm going to start off just I'm actually
bouncing off what he just said a book
recommendation for you is a book are you
write this down yeah a book called
relentless I'm forgetting the author's
name Tim something in any case he was
the personal coach to Jordan to Tiger
Woods to Berkeley to the LeBron I mean
just like any of the big names you can
think of especially in basketball he was
not their team coach he was their
personal coach not personal trainer but
personal coach he did work on the
training aspects too and worked with the
team of trainings but that's not really
what he was about he he had a way of
dealing with performers on that level on
that that level of just pure Drive these
guys that are literally never not in the
zone like they don't like nothing in
their life as ever in outside of the
zone they are always on right he tells
this great story um
and it goes like this so and I actually
went back and I watched it's true he
tells a story about Jordan and and when
he won his first championship with chips
with the Bulls and you know the crowds
down on the court and the team's lifting
him up in the air and everything else
and everyone's celebrating if you look
at his hands
how many fingers is he holding up he
just won his first world championship
literally seconds before he's holding up
two fingers second world championship
he's already over it no big deal
number three watch his fingers he's done
he achieved that goal he's already on to
the next that's what separates guys like
him from guys like me that's great
how many fingers are you going to hold
up when you win that gold medal how many
fingers are you going to hold up it's
beautiful I like that thank you very
much I just wanna I just want to say
thank you to you guys because when we
are traveling on the road and all that
stuff like that it is after simplifying
my life it has let me focus on the times
that I am at home to spend with my
family and friends since I am on the
road all the time so I just like to
thank you guys for that thanks brother
[ __ ] event thank you for coming on in
all right we got time for one more a
lightning round question I'm going to
apologize to the rest of the people in
line because we have to move on after
this but we'll do our best to answer
this last question here hi howdy I'm
again and I'm from Minneapolis
I am wondering with your sales
background do you think it is possible
for someone hint its me to to live a
minimalistic lifestyle but make a living
off of selling people things that they
don't need even if you can you
appreciate their need for those things
or well Hana Hana you you're
contradicting yourself you just said
selling the things they don't need but
then you appreciate their need for you
talking about how you can appreciate
people's lifestyle and how they they
live that way
but if somebody who I sell clothes yeah
my closet has about well we're closer
here
other pieces of clothing but when I sell
somebody 15 pieces of clothing then back
my mind I'm like they don't really need
that sure but I love what I do right so
so I mean let's talk about clothes
really really quickly right so we throw
an 88 on average the average person here
throws on 88 pounds of clothes a year
90% of the people in this room have
purchased piece of clothes within the
last 30 days nearly 100% within the last
year and the average person 30 years ago
owned nine outfits the average person
today owns more than 30 and so it's okay
the people don't need more clothes right
the question isn't always about need
remember a second ago I talked about
minor values our minor values are things
that add value to our lives Ryan and I
and Patrick aren't up here saying you
could perpetually deprive yourself of
stuff that's not what we're talking
about at all we encourage you to bring
things into your life that you a you
might need or B maybe it just adds value
to your life it is a want or a like and
that is okay as long as you're doing so
deliberately and you can afford it
now when I say afford it I don't just
mean the price tag the cost of a thing
goes way beyond the price tag but we get
so caught up on money and in this
culture which we we should think about
that when it comes to affording
something but then we discount the real
price of the thing it goes way beyond
the price tag it goes to the cost of
shopping for the thing that's the time
that it takes to go acquire the thing
right and parking it and go into the
store and then you know returning or
exchanging the thing and then changing
the things batteries changing the things
I'll putting gas
saying buying the extended warranty for
the thing the space the thing takes up
right and and then there are so many
additional costs beyond that the mental
clutter that the things calls you know
when they when they pile up in our
houses or our storage lockers old
storage lockers the cost of storing the
thing off-site because we no longer have
room for it there are all these other
costs that we don't think about needing
a bigger home with bigger closets to
store more clothes that we may not wear
and so the cost of the thing goes way
beyond the thing that's my short answer
by the way and it even goes farther for
you because the fact that you're a
siddhis question means there's an
additional cost for you right there's
what the story what's the story is about
and then what the story is really about
and what the story is really about here
is you grappling right now with with not
allowing or allowing yourself it is up
for you to your you're at you're at this
sort of fork in the road right now and
you're trying to figure out where does
the word of the bifurcate and here's
what I can tell you if your actions
don't align with your values you'll
continue to experience a chasm of
discontent oh that's a better short
answer he's that one that is a much
better short after yeah yeah I would
like my really short answer I thought it
right away was it's not for you to
decide how much is too much for someone
else so I would I would say that first
off but as I was thinking that I'm like
I don't want to give you an excuse
either right but at the end of the day
the other short answer I was thinking of
what actually it's very much in line
with what Josh was saying if you want if
you want to
live a discontented life live outside
your values and beliefs but you're
certainly not going to be happy all
right so I just want to say since Lewis
was initially described as like a kind
of rap battle sort of thing as the
person of color on the stage I won
before we even lost out there is a true
story
so um the the truth of the matter is is
that you don't know the story of the
person that you're selling those that
thing to that that blouse or that
sweater or those jeans or what have you
you know the person who comes in and
buys the buys the 15 things you may
think that because you know they're
dressed nice and they're playing with
their with their gold card and
everything else that they've got it all
together and that they're just buying
stuff for the sake of buying stuff but
you don't know that and and we really we
don't know other people's stories right
and and so the only thing that we can
really do is do what's right for us and
to know that if we're doing what's right
for us and is making us happy then that
you know I believe in karma you know and
not in this kind of necessarily like
whirligig hoody 2d version of it but
this very real version that if you are
happy those around you will be happy and
those around them will be happy and
eventually hopefully that makes the
world a better place right if you just
do your part to make it just a little
bit better and if we all do just a
little bit to make it just a little bit
better guess what if everyone's doing
that suddenly it gets a little bit
better um and so I guess if I were to
come up with a short answer it would be
this
tell your own story and by doing so you
allow others to live theirs better thank
you ladies and gentlemen Patrick Rhone
yeah give her a round of applause but
you don't go anywhere yet though we
actually I want to talk to you about one
thing real quick before we move on to
the added value segment of the show so
when we showed up to to film Patrick's
interview for our documentary minimalism
it was it was the day after Christmas
day after Christmas and all through the
house literally all through the house oh
my gosh yeah so is this this was just
hey Patrick can we show up and talk to
you about getting rid of stuff yeah so
so like I said I live with Maximus and
so yeah it was the day after Christmas
and we are the ones that host Christmas
in our family and when we do a big
Norwegian Christmas Eve celebration and
so we have all the present opening on
the Christmas Eve night and you're
actually looking at America's probably
only African American lefse maker so
there's a bonus I make some I make some
less than that Sam so um and then the
next morning and we save the lot of our
presence and we open them up Christmas
morning of Chris just for Fiat Rickson
than us my wife and and me and so we
have this mountain of stuff right we
have all the dishes still left over from
Christmas Eve dinner we've got you know
all of our you know it's our nice China
and our nice silver and all that stuff
because yes we have nice
China nice over and all of that stuff um
so much stuff so much stuff and so these
guys are like yeah we're coming it down
is how does the 26 sound great I guess
but you guys you're aware I don't live
with minimalist and therefore I this is
not like you know a minimalist lifestyle
house you know oh you know you might
have to take some candid shots or no you
cannot take candid shots around my house
no know what's at window just for your
closet no and so yeah so they came they
set up for Ryan dealing with my with my
bar key dog with the two long nails on a
hardwood floor Click Clack and around
poor poor matt and his sound method
director and it was just this comical
situation and so my wife and daughter
were like you know well you know we just
stay after Christmas we'll go and return
exchange and stuff and whatnot about how
long do you think it takes about an hour
you know I talk I can talk now
I can seriously talk and think I have a
five and a half hours of footage of us
talking yes seriously
yeah I mean I'm in the film for like
three and half minutes or is at least
three and a half hours footage I've no
lie no joke get the get the bonus
material seriously everything is in such
better context so here we are two hours
into this thing Here I am talking about
you know simplicity and minimalism and
how to live an intentional life and
everything else and how to live with
just enough and how to live with just
enough while they're surrounded with
presents and dishes and Turkey and all
sorts of other stuff and my wife and
daughter come bounding through the door
expecting us to be done with armfuls of
bags of stuff because here's the deal
like like you know not only do you do
the returns and exchanges on the 26th
but that's when you also go on u5 like
all the wrapping and stuff for next
here because like I said my wife is
super frugal and so she's like I could
get it for 75% off especially yo these
rolls are wrapping pay out lyrics I
think they had about 10 bags each as
they come bounding through the door and
I'm just like oh this is a minimalism in
here oh my gosh are they going to think
I'm a total fraud oh man so yeah that
was that was my that was my story yeah
but I here's the thing like I totally
knew better because I I also I mean I
had many conversations with Patrick
before and I also realized that
minimalism isn't it because we went out
interviewed all these different people
from different walks of life and the
people Ryan talked about whether it was
Colin it was traveling the world and
everything he owns sits in his back like
a turtle mm-hmm or Leo and his six kids
six kids that sure as hell ain't
minimalist no and and so always
obviously like minimalist when it comes
to condoms all right well time to move
on so Ryan and I talked about what's
been adding value to our lives recently
and since we are here in Minneapolis and
my partner Rebecca she is is a local gal
here from Minneapolis yeah and her whole
family hillier really early through a
large chunk of her family and so we get
a chance to come out here
Sidney frequently and I get the
opportunity to go to a few of my
favorite spots especially the coffee
here is just outstanding Ryan and I we
don't really go on tour we go on coffee
tour and do these do this you do this in
order to buy more coffee yeah yeah yeah
I figure that out so thank you for your
contributions but one of my favorite
Coffee Roasters in the entire country is
a place called dogwood I haven't had
to go there this trip but I will be
there tomorrow before we leave
so yeah dogwood coffee and then we went
out too
first time I ever been there but it was
awesome with Hetrick Patrick out there
and Joe and a few other people and it's
called spy house yeah and the call I
mean honestly so we've been on the road
for a few months now and it's the best
cup of coffee I have had this tour so
far okay um I just had dinner at Dilla's
Ethiopian place I don't know if someone
knows what I'm talking about
yeah if you haven't any Theo pian food
it is not only is it amazing food but
it's an awesome experience because you
don't use utensils it's like you get
bread it's end here it's gluten-free it
Steffes doesn't have any gluten in it
and then you just like rip the bread off
and you kind of grab the food with the
bread and it's a really amazing
experience it's really awesome food but
then earlier today I met my friend Joel
he's got a website called simple res
calm and so Josh and I we came up with
minimalist org back in like 2014 when we
were on tour and we needed an answer to
the question of hey there's some really
cool people at this event how how do I
get a hold of people that are
open-minded or that are cool like this
and before minimalized or we would just
say uh-uh Facebook OkCupid we didn't
really have a good answer so in 2002
yeah so 2014 we just basically
facilitated some meetup groups and they
meet once a month simple Rev is the same
kind of concept and what I'll say is he
has a meetup group here that is amazing
so you could if you want to like do
something more than once a month you can
go to the minimalist organ or you go to
the simple relevant but what's cool
about either those groups is that you
are going to find
open-minded people and they may not have
you know the same exact opinions that
you have but you will least be able to
find people you can talk about things
with and get some good feedback from so
I would definitely recommend Jules
website simple Rev comm and then we I
met him at a place called birch wood
cafe a place is really good too so those
are yes those are those are my
recommendations pad you got anything
it's been adding value to your life
recently Wow
I only get to pick one thing because
this is a minimalist thing or can I do
them so my my daughter actually has been
involved with a a school here in the in
the Twin Cities and st. Paul called
circus Juventus she said been doing
circus since she was two she is nine now
and I am constantly floored absolutely
floored by the people I run into in the
Twin Cities that have never heard of it
and when I tell you about it here in a
second if you've never heard of it you
will be floored that you've never heard
of it circus Juventus is the largest
youth performing circus arts school in
North America and at times depending
upon the season the world they train
over a thousand kids between the ages of
2 and 18 in the traditional European
style circus arts if you are familiar
with Cirque de Soleil think Cirque de
Soleil
but with amateur kids but wait
performing at that same level with the
same level of production the same level
of costuming the same level of of set
and and and quit like all of that so you
are watching on cirque de soleil
basically done by kids and it's the most
absolutely amazing thing in the
they just wrapped up their their spring
chill run which is kind of more of a
recital sort of thing it's still a
three-hour show and is still high
production but there's no narrative
there there they've got upcoming
performance in Washington DC they were
invited by the Smithsonian to be the
headlining act for the Smithsonian
Folklife Festival over over the fourth
of July weekend in a couple weeks on one
week on either side so they're doing
that in Washington DC the 30th June 30
and through the 9th or maybe it's the
29th through the 9th I forget but in any
case their summer show run comes up in
August there's always kind of a
different narrative theme to it it is
only their most advanced top performers
and this year's theme is called Nord
Saga basically a Norse myths and it is
fantastic
um it is some of the best entertainment
you can get for 25 bucks a ticket and
you you're going to get everything that
you'd pay 150 to 300 bucks at Cirque du
Soleil you'll get it in a longer show
with kids supporting our local youth and
I highly recommend looking into it go
online circus Juventus org and look up
what they're doing you'll see me if you
if you go I'll be out running around on
the floor because I am
one of the head one of the lead
volunteer riggers and so I I do you'll
see me with tram pieces running around
in the dark nice well one other surprise
that's adding value recently a sky steel
has been on this little short wave of
the towards the last night he's spending
with us he opened up tonight and did you
all enjoy that opening performance from
him now he has a new single out remember
back in the days you go to a record
store and you buy like a cassette single
we used to call them conceals and you
like it was a whole like sensory
experience you would open it you go to
the store you buy it and you leave and
you open it up and then you tape it set
out and you'd read the liner notes and
the dedications and who was written by
as you listen to the song and it was
just totally different experience than
now where you just go to Spotify and hit
play all or whatever and and and so you
can't really do that anymore because you
know who the hell has a cassette player
right I that's a joke because half of
people in this room over cassette player
they're the ones that were dragged here
no but I find that that that same sort
of multi-sensory experience has been
lost with music I know sky felt that as
well so he found a way to bring back the
multi-sensory experience with his new
single but it's different from anything
you've ever experienced with with music
there's a company out of Chicago called
Vosges and they make art artisan
chocolates and they paired a chocolate
with his new single and so I'm going to
ask God to come out here and play that
single while Ryan
Patrick and I eat chocolate in front of
you
ladies and gentlemen sky steel awesome
thank you all right
can I eat it right now good - so the
song is called at the waterfall and it's
a love song for the earth so Katrina
who's the chocolatier of Vosges used
some flavours - tisha she thought would
help the listener connect more deeply to
the earth and let's see how let's see
how it works let's see if it works
cheers ryan in the side of the mountain
let's see you think swimming in a big
[Music]
and not the waterfall the sound comes to
me comes to me agate ring and not the
waterfall the song you think comes to me
comes to me like a dream
[Music]
[ __ ] that's good actually I pre-diabetic
for you you can have another one go
ladies and gentlemen Scott steel and
he's dove he'll be over here with us
afterward selling you some chocolates
and his new song if you're if you're
interested in it please support him
because I'll tell you 100% of the
proceeds from everything that all the
money that goes to Sky goes to one of
his his favorite charities it's the sky
steel gas fund they get back to Brooklyn
so you can help them out with that also
Patrick will be over there with us
afterward as well and before before we
wrap it up I just want to go to right
here right now talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalist so
Ryan and I are in the middle of building
a new podcast studio in film studio and
we refuse to clutter our podcast and our
website with advertisements just because
it doesn't align with our values
personally and so we're looking for some
help if you want to contribute on a per
episode basis to our podcast you can you
can just become a patreon patron over at
the minimalists comm slash support or
you must go to the moonless calm click
on the donate button at the top and
we're looking for a buck or two an
episode that's going to give us enough
money to build a podcast studio and a
film studio so we can do a video version
of the podcast but also create a lot
more meaningful video creations over the
years we're trying to do more video
essays many documentaries interview
series live streams all kinds of stuff
so any of the money you donate none of
that goes to me Oh Ryan just to be clear
on that it is a build the studio or to
go it goes the podcast Sean because
we're trying to to pay him a full-time
living wage for being our producer he's
our tour manager he's a man with many
hats ladies and gentlemen Podcast Sean
[Applause]
so if you want to support us that is one
way if you can't afford the support its
monetarily totally understand and and no
worries you can still support us in
other ways this month which is May 2017
for every Apple podcast review we get
Ryan and I are donating 10 bucks to
charity and it's a very specific charity
this month it's called the against
malaria foundation so we have about 500
people here tonight and if each of you
went on and left a review we would save
at least one person's life tonight and
the way that works is well actually did
you know that that out of everyone who's
ever lived on planet Earth half of those
people have died from malaria half the
people who have ever lived have died
from malaria and we're trying to at
least help out with that a little bit
and so the against malaria foundation
estimates takes about thirty five
hundred dollars to save one life to buy
enough mosquito nets insecticides
treating the skin that's over the course
of a lifetime to save one life so 350
350 reviews means 3,500 bucks means one
life saved
so people listen at home who want to
want to contribute as well just take 30
seconds 60 seconds leave a review if you
love us and you want to leave us five
stars we like that if you hate us
someone dragged you here and you're like
these guys are stupid any leave us a
one-star review that's okay too we'll
still give 10 bucks in your name either
way and so we're grateful for the
opportunity to contribute that gets our
message out in front of more ears and
gets more people listening to to the
podcast but it also allows to do
something cool in in the meantime
speaking of for the people who are
listening to this at home we are in the
middle of a tour right now it's 40
cities we just announced these the
second leg of the tour it's called the
less is now tour and we're coming to a
city near you either your city or
city within a few hours drive if you're
in north america you can go to less is
now calm find all the details and dates
it'll be the rest of this year we go out
for three or four cities at a time and
so you can find all the details find a
local theatre find the date that les is
now calm I also want to thank a couple
of the folks I got I don't know we're
just went she's hidden somewhere anyway
while we're on there all she's way back
there
we're on the road Jessica Williams is
the kind of person who curates over
social media she also runs our
minimalist org stuff and she straightens
Ryan's hair most nights and so ladies
and gentlemen Jessica Williams she's
also just like just incredibly sweet
just I mean when we went to when we went
to like spy house I mean it's our world
right now so like north east is like
crazy town
and so spy house of course you know
being you know I don't know hipster
central you know was just a madhouse and
I walk in and there's not a seed to be
found in the place and before I even had
my jacket off
here she is running around finding me a
stool and you know as I get my jacket
off I was i sat down and almost before
the words came out of my mouth that like
oh I'm gonna have to go back and get the
tea I ordered she had already gone and
gotten my order and was bringing it to
me I'm like so yeah just fantastic he
deserves a lot more money than you're
giving it yes she does your plan and you
could also support Jessica at the
minimalist calm slash patreon there you
go no it's funny I don't know who's
nicer uh Sean Harding or Jessica
Williams it's so funny like they will
get into these moments where like let's
say Sean's trying to hold it door open
for Jessica and then Jessica's like no
you first and then sounds like no you
first
it's like watching like Alexa and Siri
like battle it out
it's the most endearing thing ever but
yet you're absolutely I'd second that
notion all right so I'm after the show
tonight we will about 20 minutes so
we'll take a 20-minute break and then
for those of you who want to hang out we
will do a quick line it's a hug line the
hugs are free and transferable but also
optional by the way I know that I know
some people don't they don't want the
full hug they want the full experience
and that's okay too Ryan on twitter has
been accused of hug raping people you
may want to say soft hug hard because
these guys just go hard if you don't
like to let them know well there are
three kinds of hugs right yeah you all
know about this right so you guys got
the bro hug right you just you walk up
this like the two three taps on the back
right you have the side hug or someone's
like kind of iffy about hugging even
though sort of walk up next to you and
maybe do a little half-hearted hug and
then there's the slow dance I will tell
you I am only into consensual hugs too
so we announce it though because you
live in Montana and and most people that
have guns so you have to you have to say
I'm a hugger actually this is a
concealed carry state so probably good
idea here so we'll be out there hugs
pictures we'll sign some books and all
that fun stuff I think Shawn what you
were saying earlier is that if they want
to be part of that they should stay
seated and then other people who need to
get out of here for whatever reason they
would avoid Ryan then you'll be able to
leave first after that I'll hang out -
yeah Patrick will be here he's got some
of your books here as well I do that
will be great
all right so and then one last group to
thank is how about the folks here at the
cedar yeah
[Applause]
and with Ryan's in my books if if you
leave here and you're you're like well I
want to grab a book but I I can't afford
it right now or I just didn't bring my
wallet
that's okay let us let us buy you a copy
I'd be happy to buy one for you
ditto for mine by the way Oh awesome
thank you and and just make sure you
minimize it afterwards right it doesn't
do much good on a shelf somewhere
library could certainly use it or a
friend family member give it to an enemy
and I mean we have them all over the the
cities here I don't know how big they
are in other places you've gone but we
have little free libraries all over the
place oh yeah um and I I would be
overjoyed to find any of my books in a
little free library that I frequent when
I frequent lots of them so nice and last
but not least certainly not least I want
to thank you for being here tonight I
yeah I I don't I don't know what can
tell you to come here tonight I know you
had this like our first proper tour so
you actually had to pay to get in the
door and that allows us to like pay for
the venue and and Shawn and to have
sound and microphones and all this other
cool stuff and to travel here and to not
sleep on readers floors anymore with a
proper Hampton Inn now the laps of Lalo
I did offer up my house when you come
back what was your second house we it
was my second house I offered yes
there's a story behind it yeah so uh so
you paid to get in the door but you paid
a lot more than that you you gave up
your two most precious resources night
your time and your attention and we're
really grateful for that and if you
leave here with just one message we hope
it's this love people and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for being here yell thank you so
much Minneapolis
hey Josh Ryan my name is Megan and I am
calling from Madison Wisconsin and I'm
just calling to share our message about
how raising our children with minimalism
has had an impact on our family My
partner and I we took our son Mason to
your show in the Madison area and my
brother also came along with us so we
were able to have a lot of family
discussions about living a life with
intention and keeping items that bring
us jelly so several days after we went
to the show we were making home in
homemade pinatas for Mason's birthday
party and he came outside in the garage
and hit a bunch of little toys with him
and he was putting them inside the
pinatas and I said hey Mason what are
you doing there and he looked at me and
he said hey mom this was all part of
minimalism my trash is another person's
treasure she was awesome at his birthday
party to see all the other kids that
were all excited about his his toys that
he was willing to give up so another
thing that happened is Mason was going
through and he was cleaning up his LEGO
sets and I must admit we have a lot of
my girls at her house but both of our
young boys really enjoy playing with
Legos and there's a lot of in tension
between behind is having Legos at the
toy brings a lot of joy to them and
sucks a lot of creativity and
imagination so the management area there
is this
I shall trade Lego store which our boys
love to go to and Mason tacked up on
several boxes of his LEGO sets and his
idea was to trade in a bunch of set for
one set that he was really looking
forward to having so we brought it in
and he probably traded in headsets and
left with one sattva is one set that was
really exciting to him and brought him a
lot of joy so it was a great opportunity
for us to talk as a family about keeping
items that bring us joy and intention
between had
because having those items I think some
parents may argue we should have saved
all those toys make more money off of
selling it somewhere else or save it for
the next generation but you know for us
it's very important to teach our kids of
our values and our beliefs so I just I
want to share with other parents that
this is an amazing journey to be on with
our kids and it's a great message for
them to have and even as young as our
boys are eating for they're really
they're picking up on the message in
it's bringing a lot of excitement it's
be on this journey with with our
children so I hope they can be helped to
other parents but join join the journey
of minimalism it's awesome thanks hi my
name is Ashley and I'm from Huntsville
Alabama and I don't so much have a
question as something that I wanted to
share this worked really well for us I
know something that y'all talk about
quite frequently is the fact that people
struggle with gift giving and giving
seasons and people in their lives who
may be our gift earth and they are not
and I know right not right Josh you said
that you don't believe in the whole gift
love language and I disagree with that I
do I do believe that there are people
that that is that is just a modality of
showing love for them and I don't
believe that it is inherently wrong I
believe that the problem is when they're
gifting and their need to give give
outweighs your need to receive love in a
different way and that's an issue we run
into my mother-in-law is she's
definitely a hoarder definitely a
hoarder she's an organized hoarder but
definitely a hoarder multiple storage
unit you know 3,000 square-foot house
packed full that kind of thing and she
kind of believes that over into our
lives because she loves giving things
that's just that's her way of showing
love and and that's the way that she
likes to show affection to her
grandchildren largely not that she
doesn't in other ways but that's a big
thing for her and so the episode on
hoarding really resonated with me
particularly when you were responding to
the man from Brooklyn who said my wife
is a hoarder and I'm not and you were
talking about the Tara acronym and said
that you have to get to appreciating
that person for who they are and I do I
appreciate my mother-in-law I appreciate
that she has this heart that wants to
give but it was taking over her life
because she was show up with just I
can't tell you how many things that Dawn
dish so we have the she would just show
us that watching you dish soap and paper
towels and the food that y'all don't
really eat but I'd like it but I thought
maybe you would like it and it was all
out of love but it was terribly
inconvenient at best and smothering at
worse this is Ben I'm calling actually
from Prague Czech Republic but I do live
in Sedona Arizona most of the year and
I'm just here maybe 40 well let's be
fair 60% of the time
so I had a comment I'm just kind of new
to this I mean I've gone through
different phases of getting rid of
things but never to the extent obviously
that you guys have so I would just watch
the movie I think less than a week ago
on Netflix which was thank you very much
I was great and it was just really
impressed me what you guys have done so
instead of being a glad-handing session
here I just had a I had a remark but I
forgot about it but for Josh I don't
know Josh if you've ever tried swimming
because I was a long time runner a
little heavy now said I'll run anymore
and I beat the hell out of my left knee
but I started swimming about seven years
ago and I noticed all the back pain
which for me was completely voluntary
it was marathons when I was like your
guys age I'm like fifty m61 now say 57
that would be nice but I just found
swimming and specifically freestyle and
breaststroke so you can even do the
breaststroke Josh even if you don't feel
like you're a quote-unquote swimmer
I never was I kind of learn by doing
here I mean everybody knows how to swim
life not to drown but I never saw myself
swimming you know in laying like they do
over here narrow but I've been doing it
about seven or so years and what I
noticed is all the back pain I used to
again I don't have a chronic thing and I
don't have a problem you have with your
disc but all that went away we swimming
and I find that if I don't swim for
several weeks like you know busy
traveling something like that
my backs are getting really tight again
so just wanted to throw that out to you
you know not everybody is interested in
swimming I'm sure somewhere there are
indoor pools in Missoula Montana but
also when you guys you know stay around
and you go to hotels things like that
there's almost always a pool so I'm just
saying give it a shot no everybody's
Joshua fields Milburn and I am Ryan
Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist I was just looking up the
dates for the second leg of the lessons
now torso so Ryan and I we are in the
middle of this crazy 40 city tour we're
doing a live talk about minimalism in
depth talk about minimalism we're also
recording a live version of the
minimalist podcast we're answering a
bunch of your questions in person and oh
yeah and we dish out a bunch of free
hugs after we're optional hugs yes yeah
we do hand hugs too if they if that's
your thing whatever you like we were
looking forward to seeing you on the
road you can head on over to les is now
calm but here's the cities that we're
coming to for the second leg of this 40
City tour we're going to be in Canada
again oh man I can't wait look Canada
we're going to be at Toronto Ottawa
Montreal Vancouver Calgary Edmonton but
then we're headed to the east coast of
the United States we're going to be in
Philadelphia we'll be in Manhattan and
Brooklyn two stops in New York one oh
you have you've made it well we've never
had a stop in Brooklyn so that's pretty
cool yeah and then we'll be in Salt Lake
City Denver and Phoenix heading over to
the mountains and then we're touring
internationally we'll be in Texas where
we're going to be in Austin and Dallas
and Houston and then nashville
washington DC atlanta and tampa we're
finishing off of the cell almost then
there's no better place to spend
December than in Detroit and Milwaukee
wait who told you that
our booking agent Oh perfect yeah so
we're going to be in Detroit in
Milwaukee that's we're going to finish
the lessons now tour this year Helen
over to les is now calm you can get your
tickets you can find the dates the
theaters and you can see us soon every
little thing you think that's me every
little thing you think nagging me every
little thing that's just feeding your
greed oh I bet that you decide without
it
every little singing that you got Hey
every little singing that you guys you
gotta reach for you got a grin oh I bet
that you design without so tear your
eyes
[Music]